canada loves dustin i i love canada i
love how much you party i love how much
you love country music and i love that
you accepted me and my band guys so
listen you've had this career all these
number ones all these milestones what's
next on your bucket list because i
believe you got a manifestation
no you do it that's one thing i've
learned over the years just put it out
there you've got it as crazy as it may
seem you know i tonight was was uh
monumental for me i've never got to
perform at an award show
so this was my first
hold on i've been a part of a lot of
awards no no we need to go back okay
you've never performed it in an award
this is my first award show country
musical awards show i've ever got to
perform at
so i want to continue this trend right
if we're going to manifest
i would love to
get a chance to step on stage again and
perform at an orchard i love
the tip of the hat that the awards
represent from industry peers and and
getting that just now off stage getting
to hand dallas smith single of the year
trophy feel the weight of that know what
went went into that the work that goes
into that it's just a special night and
so i would love to be a part of more of
these okay so we're manifesting like
five awards there's a lot of country
awards shows every single year so we're
gonna manifest uh a couple performances
uh are you working on new music as an
artist
absolutely i am but right now no i
literally just turned in my next album
last week
artwork and all it's done
um so wait artwork what is the artwork
is it you and a hat is it you posing
it it is me you know we kicked around
it's always been me should we do me
should we not i'm like
well yeah we probably should do me
because
you know there's
no you just want to put a face with a
thing you know so it is me and what's so
special um
and i don't want to give too much away
about it what's so special about this
next visually album is we shot all the
visuals out at my farm oh wow so
selfishly i get to kind of have that the
rest of my life going hey this is my
land in the background so that's kind of
cool it's like a little time capsule
yeah when you do hand in a new album
like that what goes through your mind
you get notes back from like the suits
oh for sure
yeah for sure we just had a couple weeks
ago we just had all the suits uh in my
life come over to my my producer studio
and i was there of course with my team
and
um
i got a great compliment you know it was
you should be proud this is
this is game changing for you we're so
proud of of this next chapter of music
and everybody's on the same page and
really excited uh for what think about
you is doing for us and and kind of
launching us into this next chapter
super exciting dustin always a pleasure
to chat with you thank you so much thank
you canada loves him